what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to a 90 Day Fiance clip
where the man says he's only 55
attracted to his fiancee oh God before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in as you guys already know my goals did
a million Subs by New Year so make sure
you guys subscribe to the channel
oh no Haram
[Music]
I can't wait
today we are out in the gym because I
that's what I want Nicole to do with me
and I'll show her that it's a really
good thing to start working out
so let's go to see if you really can do
that one
[Music]
so yeah like she has a cute face it's a
waste you might as well been born ugly
because what did you chose to do with
your body oh my God like I I bet you she
lost weight she'd be a solid seven maybe
an eight because she's cute like her
face is cute with all that blubber with
all the blubber go to the gym but I'm
not opposed to working out so for him I
think I'll go and hopefully I don't
completely hate it
let's go I used to work in a hotel and I
lost my job but if I go to America I
hope that I could walk in gym you know
three things that one of the things that
I love to do but you know whenever when
I talk to Nicole about like being
healthy she doesn't like this you
promised me that you're gonna change and
go to gym and eat healthy so that would
try it's not as easy as it do you think
it is
down he's right you are just lazy
you have firstly you have to warm your
body okay okay
saute here
as I do okay okay look at me
no I don't wanna no do it come on honey
you should do it just turn I don't have
the right broth I know it's okay just do
it one two three good
three four five he sees the potential
but you can't marry someone based on
potential ladies fellas we don't I don't
recommend that Women Marry bums just
like I don't recommend a men marry fat
chicks it's just you know I wish when
they come work out with me and to make
and to not be lazy it will be a perfect
life for each other I love both of us
time to see how you are you know I'm not
doing this just you know for housing but
I'm doing it for myself because you know
I know I want to be healthy and I want
you know to be in shape you know this is
what I want I want this for me so how
you feel
you can breathe that's because you don't
go to gyms because you don't work that's
why one I kind of respect him a little
bit he's trying to get that passport but
he's like I am not having sex with a
chick let's go two it feels good
[Music]
five
just you can get with this stuff that's
why you feel like it's very hard it's
not that's not that hard okay it's cool
let's do it for me and Men okay and for
myself and for yourself this is the
first for yourself that's good I want
you to focus okay think about now after
like one year or something how you will
look you know
I know that I love you now but in the
future well I want like a happy and
healthier family okay
oh no
sis drop that weight
I won't lie to you though she drops the
weight she's leaving your ass so it's
gonna be a double whammy you think come
on come on her he's cute right but if
she actually dropped the way I swear to
God she'd be like her face I I think
she'd be a solid seven at least so yeah
hard seven I think and just because I'm
like she's that big and her face is
still cute so she dropped it like she'd
lose weight around her face you know
this is my managers and he's debating
he's like is she right is she right at
least just adjustable six at least at
least I think she'd be a seven uh but my
point is this she could get better than
you I'm not gonna I'm not gonna try to
be rude but unemployed man from Morocco
she's only doing that because she's
obese she loses the weight she's leaving
your ass she's leaving your ass I would
like to will be great okay and want to
be healthy but I don't think I need to
change myself for a man for him to love
me you do yeah yeah because if he loves
me he should love me for who I am
do you like bombs oh she might but it's
crazy because you're not dating the fat
man she's dating then shape man it's
like do you love him for him no to be
honest it would be very hard like for
the first days but one day in the future
you're gonna thank you
there's some stuff I want you to change
up like to go to gym and like to not be
lazy I'm not lazy sometimes you are they
know you're asking of me right now I'm
what do you know what you're asking
from me right now
yeah to get on the treadmill sorry I
can't say that anymore yeah to get on
the treadmill girl
it's like come on go to gym and behold
him
if that doesn't happen I'm not sure that
I'm going to America
give me your hand
it's cool
that's good it's good now I'm sure
you're still burning your legs all your
body will be like very burning
okay nothing's going on with you just
don't worry you need 15 seconds
do you feel something in this place how
do you feel how you feel it's okay it's
just burning
I don't want you to be lazy you know
nothing's going on with you just think
that's what you're thinking okay you can
see
good good
thank God
we'll be fine honey okay okay as women
we thrive on attention now this is a
mistake that men make okay I'm gonna
tell you guys a mistake them and make I
heard entertained to say this and I was
like oh my God that's so true so a lot
of y'all won't give your girl attention
when she's doing the right things you'll
kind of get complacent oh she's she's
doing good and as women we want
attention so you know what we'll do
we'll act up and it's kind of your own
fault because because we act up because
you are giving us attention when we're
good so it's like a child like you know
the kid that always throws the temper
tantrums and it throw he throws the
temper tantrums because that's the only
way he can get his parents attention
because when he's good he doesn't get
his parents attention remember women are
children I hate to say this I hate to
say this but I gotta be the bearer of
bad news we're basically children so him
see that he's like hugging her giving
her attention when she's doing the right
thing when she worked hard that's what
you got to do with your girl if she's
active right you got to give her that
attention because otherwise she's gonna
start acting bad to get your attention
and it's kind of your own fault
[Music]
physically I'm talking to Nicole but
it's not like just like for example 55
percent
because I always want my wife to go to
gym with me and be healthy
but are you attracted to me no matter
what I I love you just please let's go
to gym together what are you attracted
to me no matter what yeah exactly
foreign
all right this is a prime example of why
we should hit the treadmill this girl
wouldn't have to be doing all this if
she had any self-esteem but she has no
self-esteem why because because
she knows she can't get better than this
and so now she has to go to another
country to get a man
um on top of that he has to bring her to
the gym and now she has to lose a bunch
of weight to get back when she could
have just lost the weight in the first
place had a little discipline
self-control
um yeah that would be my recommendation
but you know don't let me tell you how
to live your life anyways like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible